world war 2 was the largest conflict in
all of human history the largest and
bloodiest conflict and so you could
imagine it is quite complex my goal in
this video is to start giving us a
survey an overview of the war and I
won't even be able to cover it all in
this video it's really just to think
about how did things get started or what
happened in the lead-up and to start I'm
actually going to focus on Asia and the
Pacific which probably doesn't get
enough attention when we look at things
from a Western point of view but if we
go back even into the early 1900's Japan
is becoming more and more militaristic
more and more nationalistic in the early
1900's it had already occupied it had
already occupied Korea as of 1910 and in
1931 it invades Manchuria it invades
Manchuria so this right over here this
is in 1931 and it installs a puppet
state the puppet state of Manchukuo and
when we touch when we call something a
puppet state it means that there's a
government there and they kind of
pretend to be they kind of pretend to be
in charge but they're really controlled
like a puppet by someone else and in
this case it is the Empire of Japan and
we need to remember what is happening in
China in the 1930s China is embroiled in
a civil war so there is a civil war
going on in China and that civil war is
between the Nationalists the Kuomintang
and the Communists versus the Communists
the Communists led by Mao say Tung the
Kuomintang led by General Chiang
kai-shek and so they're in the midst of
the Civil War and so you can imagine
Imperial Japan is taking advantage of
this to take more and more control over
parts of China and that continues
through the 30s until we get to 1937 and
in 1937 the Japanese use some pretext
with you know kind of a kind of a false
flag kind of well I won't go into the
depths of of what started it kind of
this
Marco Polo Bridge incident but it uses
that as justifications to kind of have
an all-out war with China so in 1937
1937 you have all-out war and this is
often referred to as the second
sino-japanese war sino-japanese Japanese
war many historians actually would even
consider this the beginning of World War
two while some of them say ok this is
the beginning of the Asian Theatre of
World War two of the all-out war between
Japan and China but it isn't until
Germany invades Poland in 1939 that you
truly have the formal beginning so to
speak of World War two regardless of
whether you consider this a formal
beginning or not the second
sino-japanese war it's called the second
because there was another sino-japanese
war the late-1800s
that was called the first sino-japanese
war this is incredibly incredibly brutal
and incredibly a bloody a lot of
civilians affected we could do a whole
series of videos just on that but at
this point it does become all-out war
and this causes the Civil War to take a
backseat to fighting off the aggressor
of Japan in 1937
so that lays a foundation for what's
happening in the Pacific in the run-up
to World War two and let's also remind
ourselves what's happening what's
happening in Europe as we go through the
1930s Hitler's Germany the Nazi Party is
getting more and more militaristic so
this is Nazi Germany Nazi Germany right
over here they're allied with Benito
Mussolini's Italy they're both extremely
nationalistic they both do not like the
Communists at all you might remember
that in 1938 1938 you have the on
sluiced which I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing and you also have the
takeover the Sudetenland in
Czechoslovakia so the Anschluss was the
unification with Austria and then you
have the Germans taking over the
Sudetenland in Czechoslovakia and this
is kind of the famous you know the rest
of the what will be called the Allied
power is kind of saying ok yeah ok
Hitler's just going to do that well
let's we don't want to start another war
we still all remember World War one it
was really horrible and so they kind of
appease Hitler and he's able to kind of
satisfy satisfy his aggression so in
1938 you have Austria Austria and the
Sudetenland and the Sudeten Sudetenland
are taken over are taken over by Germany
and then as you go into 1939 as you go
into 1939 in March they're able to take
over all of Czechoslovakia they're able
to take over all of Czechoslovakia and
once again the Allies are kind of
they're feeling very uncomfortable they
kind of have seen something like this
before they they would like to push back
but they still are kind of are not
feeling good about starting another
World War but so they're hoping that
maybe Germany stops there so let me
write this down so all of all of
Czechoslovakia check go Slovakia is
taken over by the Germans this is in
this is in March of 1939 and then in
August in August you have the Germans
and this is really in preparation for
what you could guess is about to happen
for the all-out war that's about to
happen the Germans don't want to fight
the Soviets right out the gate as we
will see and as you might know they do
eventually do they do eventually take on
the Soviet Union but in 1939 they get
into a pact with the Soviet Union and so
this is they sign the Molotov Molotov
Ribbentrop Ribbentrop Ribbentrop pact
with the Soviet Union this is in August
which is essentially a mutual
non-aggression hey you know you do what
you need to do we know what we need to
do and they secretly started saying okay
we're going to in all of these countries
out here we're going to create these
spheres of influence where Germany can
take control of part of it and the
Soviet Union and Stalin is in charge of
the stove it Union at this point can
take over other parts of it and then
that leads us to the formal start we're
in September right this is a different
color so September of 1939 on September
1st Germany in vain
ADEs Poland Germany invades Poland on
September 1st which is generally
considered the beginning of World War 2
and then you have the the Great Britain
and France declares war on Germany so
let me write this world war ii world war
ii world war ii starts everyone is
declaring war on each other Germany
invades Poland Great Britain and France
declare war on Germany and you have to
remember at this point
Stalin isn't so concerned about Hitler
he's just signed the Molotov Ribbentrop
pact and so at the in mid-september
Stalin himself invades Poland Poland as
well so they both can kind of carve out
they both can carve out their spheres
their spheres of influence so you can
definitely sense that things are not
looking good for the world at this point
you already have Asia in the second
sino-japanese war incredibly bloody war
and now you have kind of a lot of very
similar actors that you had in World War
one and in there starting to get into a
fairly extensive engagement